wer verletzt ist erkannt ins krankenhaus
auf kann man sich verlassen eigentlich
und natürlich wenn man verletzt ist dann
muss das auch sehr schnell gehen ja nach
diesem schrecklichen unfall hier war das
aber erstmal nicht so in bayern da
brauchte ein 13 jahre altes mädchen
wirklich schwer verletzte aus dem wrack
geschnitten so schnell wie möglich
natürlich die beste notfallhilfe und
bekam sie erst mal aber nicht
krankenhäuser haben nein gesagt zu ihr
was genau ist da passiert
plötzlich ist der rote vw sportwagen auf
der allee im berchtesgadener land ins
schleudern geraten ein furchtbarer crash
trümmer zwei eingeklemmte darunter ein
mädchen vor ort versuchen über 70
rettungskräfte die 13 jährige bei einer
so genannten crash bergung aus dem wagen
zu befreien das heißt bergung so schnell
wie möglich es geht um leben und tod
doch als die 13 jährige endlich befreit
wird der schock eines der umliegenden
krankenhäuser ist bereit das mädchen
aufzunehmen der grund zu wenige
intensivbetten der notarzt am unfallort
versucht das kind in den umliegenden
kliniken traunstein murnau münchen und
salzburg unterzubringen doch die
verweigern die aufnahme des schwer
verletzten mädchens der leitende notarzt
macht druck er droht den kliniken mit
einer zwangseinweisung das klinikum
passau erklärt sich schließlich bereit
das mädchen aufzunehmen fatal passau ist
200 kilometer von der unfallstelle
entfernt
die verletzte muss erst in den
rettungshubschrauber geladen und dann 35
minuten nach passau geflogen werden und
das während das mädchen mit dem tod
kämpft warum dieser irrsinn warum nimmt
kein krankenhaus das schwer verletzte
mädchen auf
personalmangel und corona so heißt es
der notstand in den kliniken sei groß
auch die anderen verletzten werden in
verschiedene kliniken nach bad
reichenhall traunstein und sogar ins
österreichische salzburg transportiert
so auch der vater des mädchens er liegt
jetzt 100 kilometer von seiner tochter
entfernt
[Musik]
darüber müssen wir sprechen unsere
reporter ferdinand dorf lasst uns
zugeschaltet hallo ferdinand guten
morgen es ist normal dass man schauen
muss welches krankenhaus kapazitäten hat
aber es ist natürlich auch klar es muss
schnell gehen ein kind schwer verletzt
und dann dieses wirrwarr wie konnte das
zustandekommen gibt es eigentlich
erklärungen
die erklärung prinzipiell ist
maximale überlastung der kliniken wir
haben an dem tag sehr viele unfälle
gehabt sehr viele schockraum so kamen
diesmal das übernimmt der institute also
die einrichtung im krankenhaus und das
kind hat einfach das pech dass die
schock räume aufgeführt waren das
landeskrankenhaus salzburg was am
nächsten gelegen ist hatte den vater
übernommen und man braucht bei seinen
schwer verletzten kindern ja auch oder
personen bei kindern eine spezialisierte
auf kinderklinik das ist immerhin ein
kind und kein erwachsener und das ist
das große problem gewesen weswegen hier
wirklich unter zeitdruck gearbeitet
wurde und dann diese weite verlegung und
dann wurde hin und her telefoniert
minuten lang du hast das alles dort
mitverfolgt wie lange hat das gedauert
am ende länger als das mädchen aus dem
wrack zu schneiden
also laut feuerwehr haben die feuerwehr
hat und die 4 17 minuten gebraucht 17
bis 19 minuten um diese schwerst
eingeklemmte kind zu befreien mittels
gleich bergung so eine bergung wenn die
17 minuten dem crash verfahren brauchen
braucht normal sind 40 50 minuten im
normalen verfahren wenn du ups gerecht
also alles freischneider ist und dann
die person befreit und dann ist es eine
runde 30 minuten im rettungswagen
gestanden also versorgt worden aber dann
wird uns waren ist einfach keine
intensivstation da kannst du nur ad
management marken also personen
stabilisieren und so und hat gewartet
auf das krankenhaus das aufnimmt und das
ist halt das wesen problem und passau
hat sich dann bereit erklärt es ist ein
sehr weiter weg weil das sind dann noch
mal 35 minuten und es gibt im
rettungsdienst die klare regel gold
mauer wie schlaganfall und so weiter ist
auch beim polit drama innerhalb der
ersten stunde sollten sie der
maximalversorgung zugeführt werden
und hier hat man wirklich wertvolle zeit
verloren ich finde auch wenn man sich
denkt da liegt meine tochter irgendwo
ist wahnsinnig weit entfernt für die
eltern der vater weiter untergebracht
wichtigste frage wie geht es dem mädchen
13 jahre ist sie alt und musste so lange
darauf warten bis sie dann auch wirklich
in der intensivstation liegt
medizinische versorgung die sie dringend
braucht ihr geht's ja
wir wissen wir da nicht die polizei hält
sich bedeckt also es heißt sich ist
lebensgefährlich verletzt sie wurde vor
ort intubiert und beatmet davon können
wir ausgehen dass sie weiterhin
intubiert und beatmet ist
und ihr vater ist ebenfalls als schwerst
verletzt und ins landeskrankenhaus und
er liegt uns ein so genanntes
krankenhaus in lofer chirurgie
universitätsklinik auf der
intensivstation
es ist ein sehr tragisches ereignis
gewesen was leider tagtäglich auftritt
also wir haben die aufnahmen den
kliniken hier in der region momentan
häufig das lange diskutiert wird lange
telefoniert wird wo ist was für ein 13
jahre altes mädchen schwer verletzt dort
bei diesem tragischen unfall in
teisendorf als am südlichsten zipfel von
deutschland wird dann innerhalb von
einer guten viertelstunde aus diesem
wrack befreit und es dauert eine halbe
stunde um ein krankenhaus zu finden das
ja berichtet uns unser bild reporter
ferdinand löffler danke dir vielen dank
[Musik]